So we need to determine how many
records are in the appended data set.
Let's first start by looking at
the data in the two input tools.
The first data set has StreamNumber,
ID, firstName, and lastName.
The second data set has the same fields,
but they're in a different order
with StreamNumber coming in first, and
then the lastName, firstName and ID.
To append this data sets together,
we grab the Union tool and
drop it next to the top data set.
Then we manually create an arrow
connecting the lower data set.
The default method is to
use Auto Configure by Name.
So although the fields
are in a different order,
when we run the work flow,
they will be lined up because they're
lining up based on the field names.
[SOUND] We can see that we have
eight records total that come out of
the Union tool.
However, if you wanted to
count them using a tool,
you could bring in the tool
called Count Records.
I find it by searching on
the word count in the search bar.
Find the tool called Count Records and
attach it to the Union tool.
Then run the work flow to see
the total number of records, 8.